and Appelbaum author of gulag a history
at the end of your book in the epilogue
you talk about a cruise that you had or
boat trip back in 1998 do you remember
that I remember it well
recounted for us what were the
circumstances it was actually it was an
overnight ferry from the city of our
hangul sck in the far north of Russia to
the salafi etske islands these islands
were they were the site of the first
really the first camp the gulag the
Soviet Union's first major political
camp that was actually run by the secret
police and I of course was going to see
a concentration camp but most of the
people on the ship were there because it
was a kind of pleasure cruise it was the
islands are very beautiful and they were
there to sort of have a good time and we
were all assigned tables and I was i sat
next to i sat with a group of people who
were from a city down the down the river
and they asked me you know they were
they found it very amusing that they had
an American on the boat and they said to
me what are you doing here
and I said well I'm writing a book about
Soviet concentration camps and I'm going
to see the salafi at Sea Islands for
that reason and there was a kind of dead
silence and a real moment of
unpleasantness as they said you know you
know one of them said well what it would
it would what business is it of yours
you know why do you need why do you care
about it you know this is this is our
problem not yours and another person
said one of the other ones said well why
don't you write about something nice in
our history you know we went to the moon
and meaning read the Soviet Union even
though Soviet Union no longer existed
and you you foreigners always focus on
the bad things one of the women said no
you're right I think it's it's an
interesting thing that you're doing and
it's worthwhile and another one never
said anything at all just sat listening
quietly as I tried to describe my trip
and it's the reason I use this incident
in the book is it struck me as very
typical of the wide range of reactions
Russian contemporary Russian reactions
to this kind of history some people
become angry about it some people don't
want to know about it a few people
consider it important and wish they knew
more and most people would just rather
not talk about it at all it was 1998 you
say in that same chapter that epilogue
you speak Russian I do speak important
was that or is that to you understanding
this whole story very I mean to all of
the 90% of what's written about it was
written in Russian all the archives are
in Russian I had to conduct interviews
in Russian it's a it's a you know to
understand the nuances of it I mean it
may be that my Russian well it was
certainly enough to do that but I mean
there that it's a very nuanced and
complicated history and you would have
to be able to speak to people about it
you also say I don't know what is in
this chapter not that the Russians have
never investigated that whole story this
whole story you're writing about never
like the unlike the Nazis did like the
German well they it's complicated
because there have been two moments in
Russian history when they did talk about
it publicly one was right after Stalin
died there was very brief moment when it
was sort of half discussed in the
Khrushchev era then sort of quickly
buried again after Khrushchev fell then
in the in the mid-1980s when perestroika
began in the area in the year of glass
toast there began to be a public debate
as well in Sultan Eaton who wrote the
first great book on the Soviet camps was
published and there wasn't a great
interest in the past and that ended then
very quickly and by the time I was going
to Russia in the 90s people had really
lost interest in this subject and I
think what is particularly important is
that the there was no official interest
in it and when I compare it to the
Germany after the war you know Germany
after the war held trials there was a
constant debate nowadays there museums
in Russia there's none of that there's a
sort of official silence occasionally a
little bit of money given to given to
victims but but but there's no there's
no real public acceptance of
responsibility for what happened and
that is very different what does gulag
mean it's an acronym and it means main
camp system main camp administrative
system it's and it was it really
actually the word was popularized by
Solzhenitsyn who took the acronym which
describes the administrative body that
ran the gulag and used it to describe
the camp system what was it the gulag
the gulag was a system of concentration
camps and administration of camps at its
the most comprehensive count we have is
something like 476 camps each one of
each camp though contained was a camp
complex could contained up to many
thousands of smaller camps it was a
network of prison labor that stretched
all across the Soviet Union what were
the years that the gulag existed it it
really some forma that existed from 1918
until the end of the Soviet Union in
1991 but the really important years were
from about 1929 until Stalin's death in
1953 and those were the years when the
gulag was a very important part of the
Soviet economy and was contributed
enormous amount to the Soviet mentality
there were camps before that and they
were camps after that but they didn't
have quite the same significance why did
it start it started it sort of it
started as a cup for several reasons but
I suppose the most important reason was
that Stalin was in 1929 was carrying out
something called the five-year plan
which was an attempt to industrialize
the Soviet Union very quickly and there
were one of the side effects of the
five-year plan was that a great number
of people were arrested and there was a
during a process called collectivization
when all the when the Soviet farms were
made into state farms peasants were made
into state farms many many people were
arrested this meant that this meant that
they had an enormous number of prisoners
they wanted to industrialize Stalin came
up with you really probably came from
Stalin came up with the idea that the
cat that we could use prison labor to
speed up industrialization and it was a
sort of it was a combination of both of
those things back in the back of the
Appendix you have from the year 1930
until the Year 1953 a list of the number
of people that were in the system and
it'll be hard for the audience to see
that but the biggest year was 1955
d two million five hundred and sixty one
thousand plus what do these numbers mean
those numbers you have to be very
careful with because in fact the camp
system was in constant flux people were
there were waves of arrests and then
waves of releases people were released
for all kinds of reasons they were
released into the Red Army during the
war they were released because the
system decided it had too many people so
it might pregnant women out or if there
were there was various reasons those
numbers represent the average while the
the official total number of people in
camps in that particular year on January
the 1st of that particular year if you
add up all together number of people who
were in the camps at one point or
another you get much higher numbers you
get 15 18 million and there were
different years where it they changed I
mean the you show in your book that more
people went through than other years
what were the different over those years
from 1929 up through 1950 where all the
way up through the 80s what were the big
years and why there were some big years
in the early 30s when this wave of
peasants came into the camps there was
another spike in 1937 this was the year
so the so-called Great Purge
when Stalin began Stalin and his
henchmen began arresting high party
members and there was an enormous wave
just after the war and after the war you
had pouring into the camps you had
people from the territories that the
Soviet Union had conquered you had
Russians who'd fought in the West being
arrested upon their return to Russia
Soviet citizens being returning to the
Soviet Union
you had an enormous new categories of
prisoners in those years 1948 is another
year when Stalin once again began after
kind of there was a sort of slightly
looser feeling after the war he once
again clamped down and that was another
year of mass arrests and it was it was
connected to ideology was connected to
international politics the waves of
arrests
how many people did you talk to that it
had actually been in the camps I did
formal interviews of about 30 people
meaning that I sat down with him for
several hours and recorded in her
I probably talked to twice that number
I mean I've met maybe 50 60 70 people
because I met people all over the place
who had some experience or who if they
hadn't been specifically in camps had
been in exile which was another way of
another form of mass repression and
punishment so many people I've met
people in other countries too who had
been in the Soviet system Hungarians
poles had been in the Soviet camps pick
an interesting one and tell us the story
Susana Pechora is a woman who had was
very unusual in the Soviet Union in that
she was actually part of a very small
very amateurish but very authentic
anti-stalinist group there was virtually
no opposition in the soviet union there
was no mass opposition until much later
on and in Stalin's era there was nothing
she together with a little group of
school friends and they were sort of
1718 founded a little what they just
thought of as a kind of revolutionary
group there were there a few then they
established a kind of system where of
secrecy and they had meetings I don't
think they did very much
but one of them betrayed the whole group
to the secret police and they were all
arrested they were sent all over the
Soviet Union one or two of them were
executed she was sent to the far north
to one of the most difficult camps
what's amazing about Susanna Petra is
that she never lost her energy or her
enthusiasm or her belief that the Soviet
system was wrong you know they didn't
beat it out of her she never had any
difficulty afterwards talking about what
had happened as soon as it became
possible in the 1980s she became one of
the founders of Memorial which was one
is today the only organization that is
truly preoccupied with the history of
the camps in the history of Stalinism in
Russia where does she live she now lives
in Moscow how long was she in the gulag
she was not in very long because she was
arrested late it was in the 50s she was
actually in Cannes for I think five six
years what was the experience for her
like
it was you know I think one of the set
to me was she was very young and in that
sense she she was for example before she
was in the camp she was in prison for a
long time and she said to me you know
when you're a young person you don't
have resources to draw on you don't have
memories you don't have things to think
about
and so for her it was it was an
experience of you know solitary was you
know she had she had to she had to sort
of figure out who she was and come up
with things to think of and and tell
herself stories it was an I suppose it
was an it did it was it was an
experience that I suppose could have it
made her more of what she was I suppose
it made her she was she knew there was
something she sensed there was something
wrong with the system and it made her
more so it gave her kind of conviction
you talked in your introduction about
walking across the Charles Bridge in
Prague Czechoslovakia and seeing
something that really led to this book
what was it so the only thing that led
smoke but I saw people selling little
Lenin and Stalin pins and I saw lots of
foreign tourists buying them they were
the sort of kind of communist
bric-a-brac that that used to be
available quite easily in the Soviet
Union you know sort of Red Army caps
with stars on them and belts Soviet Army
belts and little pins and with pictures
of Lenin and Stalin and I just looked at
that and I thought you know if this if
if these were if this was Nazi
memorabilia for sale nobody would buy it
and it was that sort of that's that's an
incident that I use as a representative
of other experiences I've had that have
led me to realize that the experience of
the glug doesn't have the same
significance for us in the West or
really in some again some cases any
significance for us that the Nazi
experience had and there are good
reasons for that but it led me to become
intrigued with the subject and and
follow it further
why were you in that part of the world
in the first place I was spent a long
time in that part of the world I was
originally my first thing I did as a
grownup was to go to Warsaw and be the
worst correspondent for The Economist
and that was in 1989 where had you been
before that I had been in University in
England yes where at Oxford and why did
you choose to work for the Economist and
go to Warsaw what was that all about I
had studied Russian in college I had
been to Eastern Europe a couple of times
I was actually involved with a group
that was helping to fund some of the
dissident movements in Warsaw and at one
point it doesn't have a name I mean it
was it it was run out of England was and
it's not a secret anymore but it was it
was just sort of sympathizers with the
dissident movement how did you get
involved with the group it was run by a
group of Oxford students really and one
of them was a friend of mine who was all
involved in the in Poland in particular
and he asked me if I'd like to go at one
time and bring money to some of the
people and I did it and what was that
whole experience like how long did it
last
not long I mean I I wasn't this wasn't
until that 1988 which was really the end
and everything was already falling apart
and so and I just went back and forth a
couple of times so then the this book
several years later though was a result
of what what new information did you get
my book your book yes my book I began a
few years after that I mean I didn't
really begin working on it till much
towards the end of the 90s and by that
time there was a tremendous amount of
information available most importantly
the Soviet archives are open they're not
all open there's probably still a lot of
personal information on Stalin and the
leadership that's not open but there's a
tremendous amount that is open and there
are tremendous number of people
particular in Russia who've been working
on it and that was that's all new did
you live in the Soviet um I didn't live
well by the time I was doing and it was
Russia not the Soviet Union I didn't
live there I lived in Warsaw and I went
back and forth
spend a month here in a month there and
go back and forth I know from our
previous interview we had that you
married someone from Poland it was in
the hood in the government I did he was
he was that's why I was more so actually
for the last few years done so I was I
was married to him and and what did he
do in the Polish government he was the
deputy foreign minister and what does he
do today he's at the American Enterprise
Institute in Washington and so we go
back to the the basics here you cite in
your introduction that the American Left
has basically ignored a lot of what
Stalin or Khrushchev or that whole
Soviet system generated a part of the
American left I don't think all the
American left it's not fair to say and
also of course it's been different at
different times in history and right now
it's probably pretty hard to find
anybody even on the far left who's who
would think the civil union was a nice
place I mean you do meet one or two but
but yes there is a long history of if
not exactly covering up Stalinist crimes
then wanting to downplay them I'm really
you know it was it was it wasn't so much
this in this country Stalinist versus
Pro Stalinist versus anti Stalin
people who were very anti-stalinist
against people who were nervous about
America's role in the Cold War and did
never wanted to play up Soviet crimes
because that would somehow justify
America's role in the Cold War and it
really became the whole subject of the
Soviet Union became politicized and the
study the history of the Soviet Union
became politicized which made it was
another reason why it was so difficult
to write in the past and is so much
easier to write now why did the gulag
start in the first place who started it
the gulag began in 1912
the first camps were founded directly
after the Bolshevik Revolution by Lenin
under his order his he and Trotsky
ordered the setting up of camps for
enemies enemies of the people and people
who were in the way of the revolution
this is right at the beginning in 1918
there were camps for enemies of various
kinds throughout the 1920s in 1929
however
Stalin took a decision to expand the
camp system and to make it a far more
important part of the Soviet economy and
he he he began to use the camps for
particularly economic goals you know to
dig the White Sea canal or to dig for
coal and the far north and it was
particularly used in bits of the Soviet
Union that were almost uninhabitable the
very very far north or the deserts where
prison labor you didn't have to entice
people to go there prisoners could be
forced to go there and work why were
people picked to go to the camps in the
first place well people were arrested
for what
well the gulag was partly for political
prisoners and by political prisoners in
the Soviet Union I mean people who were
arrested on spurious political charges
99 percent of the time so they would be
they would tell a joke about Stalin and
then they would be arrested for being
counter revolutionaries or their
neighbor you know wanted to get hold of
their apartment so the neighbor would
accuse them of having committing treason
and then they would be arrested for
treason throughout the 30s and 40s there
was a sort of a climate of paranoia and
unreasonable 'ti that's difficult to
explain today where traffic crossing any
line or being thought to have crossed
any line critical criticizing
authorities in any way could result in a
cab sentence there were also criminals
in the camps and there was also a third
category of prisoner the Soviet Union
had very very strict work laws so if you
were late to work too many times you
could be arrested this is particularly
during the war and if you switch to your
place of work without telling the
authorities you could be arrested and
there were people sent to the camps for
those kinds of reasons too there was a
what REME Li wide range of people there
from all social classes all walks of
life of the four hundred in some camps
that you mentioned where were they
located in the country there you say
there are 12 time zones in Soviet Union
they were everywhere there were camps in
Moscow after the war large parts of
Moscow were built and rebuilt by
prisoners there were camps all over the
far north
where their oil mines oil we have oil
fields and coal mines pretty much every
major city had a camp pretty much every
province had a cab or a group of
prisoners over a group of prisons it
would have been hard to live your life
in the Soviet Union to go through daily
life and not be aware of the camps how
big were the camps they varied
tremendously there were some sort of
industrial sized camps
which contained tens of thousands of
people there were some very small ones
connected to particular factories or
particular workshops that might just be
a few dozen people give us if you can an
example and take somebody through the
whole process of who was arrested
how were they dealt with then how did
they get to the camps and once they got
to the camps what was their life life
can you think of anybody that you talked
to well here's a person who will be
interesting to this audience I think who
I didn't speak to but who read a very
very good autobiography he was somebody
called Alexander Dogen and he was an
American who worked for the American
Embassy in Moscow who was picked up off
the street in 1946 he was very young he
was in his 20s and he was a sort of very
high spirited young man who used to
steal his superiors cars drive around
Moscow pick up girls and so on and
because of this the KGB suspected that
he was in fact more senior than his post
he was a Clark would would would
otherwise have indicated and they
thought he was a spy manner of just a
second 1946 what was the atmosphere and
the relationship between the Soviets and
the Americans this was just the very
beginning of the Cold War World War two
is over World War two as ever the Cold
War is beginning and the the alliance
between the United States and the Soviet
Union that had lasted to the war was
beginning to freeze as the Soviet Union
was had marched into Eastern Europe and
appeared not to be staying as it opposed
America in various other places it has
to be said that the Soviet hysteria and
fear of Americans who lived in their
country never ended during the war even
during the Alliance even when we were
allies but after the war that paranoia
became much sharper and harsher so this
was Alexander Dole
he was a young man he was picked up off
the street he was walking down the
street and someone said hey Alexander
and he turned around and someone said
come here with me and he was pulled into
a car and driven away he never had time
to talk to his embassy he never had time
to tell anybody where he was going he
disappeared he was taken immediately to
one of Moscow's harshest prisons where
he was interrogated for several months
his experience was in some ways unusual
because he was arrested he was genuinely
thought to be a spy and that they
thought he really might be a spy so he
was interrogated with great seriousness
and he was beaten and he was he was kept
up all night he was not allowed to sleep
he was he was tortured during
interrogation at other times people were
arrested when in times of mass arrests
often it was very perfunctory people
would just be arrested stamp sent away
with that much investigation he was
arrested he was then put on a train and
these trains were there were several
different kinds of train but these the
most common kind of train was really
just a cattle car it was an empty boxcar
they would put 30 men in the car there
would be a hole the bottom of the car to
use as a toilet they would be given
virtually no food except for dry bread
and saltfish the great torment of the of
the of the transport was actually that
they were given very little water so he
was taken very little food very little
water and he was taken to Colima which
was in the very very far east of the
Soviet Union it's the on the Pacific
coast and it also happens to be a place
where there are gold mines as well as
uranium and all kinds of other minerals
so he was taken there as far as I recall
he was that he was there he was there
for a good decade because he was there
until well after Stalin's death let me
ask you about a couple things and this
is this is not a pleasant subject but
you write about it in your book the hole
in the car you say would become frozen
if it were cold part of the winter and
eight months there ten months of the
year often is freezing and so they
couldn't use the hole to relieve their
waste and so what would happen in these
cars if they were in there for days well
they would ship other holes they would
use they would use somebody's shirt and
it's and how often when they were
transporting people to the gods were
their men and women and children in
these cars together there were in the
not in the not the prisoners being taken
to camps but there were mixed carriages
of people who were being deported this
is another category of arrests because
you could be arrested and sent to a camp
or you could be arrested and sent to
live in an exiled village and the cars
to the exiled villages were full of men
and women and children and these were
particularly horrific because small
children got sick they were unable to
get aspirin they got high fevers they
died old people were unable to walk they
were incontinent they died when they
were in one of these cars and people did
die in the cars what would they do with
the bodies the body would be taken out
and buried or left by the side of the
train track was there ever time they
just stacked him up in the cars himself
um I'm sure there were I I'm not sure
I've remember describing that at one
point you described in one of these
stories were the the men would I don't
know I can't even describe it where you
would in order to stack them in there
they would put their back against the
wall and spread their legs and then that
person would that was to get people in
the trucks to that was to get yes to get
people into the trucks to go to the
train station they wouldn't to get so
many people in they would make the men
sit with their legs apart and each set
one in front of the other so that like
sardines they would be all lined up to
get more people into a small space I'm
not sure they actually transported
people for days and days like that but
that was that was a method of getting
lots of people into a truck to take them
to the train station so you could be
there for a couple of days hi Alexander
dolmens story he wrote memoirs which
were actually published in this country
20 years ago
and that's another part of this book you
you got to a lot of them that haven't
been
publish there are a lot that haven't
been published there are a lot that
exists only in foreign languages I read
polish as well as Russian and there are
polish and Russian memoirs that haven't
been translated where do you find them
there are different people who collect
them in Moscow there are a couple of
sort of private libraries one one boat
by this organization Memorial collects
memoirs people gave them to me I
travelled around the country a lot I was
was often given memoirs either by people
I met or there would be a local group a
local memorial group who would give me
the local memoirs there are little local
libraries that have them you cite
Alexander Solzhenitsyn Gulag Archipelago
1962 72 72 what's in your book it wasn't
in his for instance the archives are the
main difference I mean he also had many
memoirs I probably have a wider range of
memoirs because more available now than
they were to him the big difference is
that I am able to use both memoirs and
archives so that I can show what the
official line was as well as what people
were experiencing it makes my book a
different kind of book I don't know that
it's better or more valuable but it's
it's a it's it shows up other facets of
life that he was unable to show the
importance of his book was really the
timing of it and the monumentality of it
that it was it was produced at a time
when the Soviet Union was still closed
when few people in the West really knew
this story and it was eye-opening for
millions of people my book is not that
because we do know this story already
but it does contain material and points
of view that he wouldn't have been able
to have and how did he publish his book
well he didn't publish it in Russia it
was published in the West but I mean
how'd that happen
it was smuggled out and it was published
in the West in the 70s and three parts
and it was not published in the Soviet
Union until the late 1980s after
Gorbachev class nosed and when did he
leave the Soviet Union he was expelled
he was actually kicked out of the Soviet
for writing the the gulag book I think
it was 1976 and then he went back he
went back recently he went
like in the last year's he lives there
now what wind up in there two numbers
that I remember from your book 18
million and six million six million
being the special expertise yes what's
the difference I know these numbers are
here engine 818 million is my guess
really at how many people went through
the camp system between 1918 and and the
end of the Soviet Union and that takes
into account the numbers that we were
talking about before the yearly numbers
as well as accounts for accounting for
turnover the six million number is the
nut ism is actually quite a good number
with lots of archival evidence behind it
which is how many people were deported
that means people who were arrested and
sent to exile communities not they
weren't put to camps they were sent to
distant villages in the far north or in
the Kazakh desert to live and this
included the Chechens pretty much the
entire chechen nation was deported
during the war still and thought they
were an enemy nation there were several
other nations like this the crimean
tatars the volga germans who lived in
the volga
this included the kulaks which of the
these are the peasants who came from the
collectivized farms the early in the
early 1930s late 1920s who were removed
from their farms and sent away because
it was felt that they were hampering the
progress of collective agriculture and
the process of deportation was in some
ways almost as horrific as being sent to
a camp because you were put in a village
and you were not given any food or any
money and or sometimes it wasn't even a
village there they were you were told to
build it and it was a very isolated
place where you knew nobody and many
people died there as well what did they
think they were getting out of this all
these leaders over the years stalin
believed very deeply and there's a lot
of evidence for this that the camp's
were economically productive and that he
was he had he was making money out of
them and he retained till the very end
of his life in fascination with how much
gold they were producing how much oil
they were producing how much he was
getting out of them there is of course
now lots of evidence
that shows that precisely the opposite
was true the camps were not productive
they were tremendously wasteful they
were very badly run when you have prison
labor instead of instead of specialists
you don't you aren't able to Romney's
were very sophisticated enterprises coal
mines and chemical factories and they
were they were because they were run by
effectively by slave laborers they
tended not to be run particularly well
there's an interesting example which is
the city of Vorkuta this is a coal
mining city in the very far north north
of the Arctic Circle
now Vorkuta is a city that shouldn't
exist and when you have that kind of
coal deposit somewhere like Canada what
they what the Canadians would do would
be to send in a team of miners they
would work for two weeks this is in the
poem the permafrost and then send them
home for two weeks and then rotate and
send another to it instead of doing that
instead of running the coal mines
because it's a terribly unpleasant place
to live
Stalin actually built a city north of
the Arctic Circle heating this city now
costs more than the value of the coal
that is dug up by the mines there it is
actually a pointless City I mean it has
a university it has kindergartens this
isn't a part of the world where it's
dark six months of the year and cold for
ten months of the year and snow for
eight months of the year it was a missed
development of the Soviet Union and it
was made possible by slave labor because
he could just send prisoners up there
tell them to build the city and they had
to build it how many of the people in
the Soviet Union knew that these camps
existed and how many knew the stories
everybody knew the camp's existed I
don't think there's an it isn't it isn't
like Nazi Germany where there seemed to
have been people who genuinely didn't
know that they were so much a part of
life and people were so aware of them
that they knew how many people knew the
the stunning stories of what happened
people do that it's harder to say
certainly Solzhenitsyn's book was a
revelation to many people in the Soviet
Union when it was published in the 70s
because people people in Stalin's era
didn't necessarily tell their children
what had happened even people who'd been
in the camps came back and didn't
necessarily tell their families what had
happened people were really afraid
to talk to each other so I think
probably the answer is that I can't give
you a number but I wouldn't say that a
majority of people knew very much about
what had actually happened there you've
got a lot of photographs in the book I'm
just going to hold them up and ask you
to tell me what do you see when you see
these pictures right here those are
pictures of Polish children actually
those are those are children of
deportees those are children who were
taken from their homes and sent to
communities in the far north where as
I've just described they had very little
to eat and their parents often died and
they were these pictures were taken at
the end of the war during the war really
when the poles were allowed to go out
and on the other side on the other side
the picture on the top is a camp
maternity hospital there were babies
born in the camps men and women were
supposed to be kept separate but they
weren't and the men they were often
mixed either through sloppiness or
through the men would actually break
into the women's camps and there were
tremendous number of babies born in the
camps that's that's what the top picture
is the bottom picture is a really
extraordinary picture may not seem so at
first but it's was given to me by a
woman who worked in a camp orphanage and
she gave me this picture as a way of
showing me she was defending her job
that she had and she said that the
children in the orphanage were really
very happy and this was their Christmas
tree and they were see they were
decorating a tree so life wasn't so
terribly bad this is a picture of it
what the cut line says a crowded
barracks where's that that's that's
actually a pig that's an interesting
picture - that's actually a picture from
the official NKVD meeting the secret
police archives and that was a
propaganda picture so you see everybody
in the pictures seems to be very well
clothed and they're sitting very neatly
then posing for the camera if you read
accounts of barracks it was usually far
more chaotic than that there would have
been clothes hanging from the ceiling
clothes drying on the beds and so on but
that I think gives you some idea of how
many people were in one place I think
that's from Vorkuta this says a
punishment isolator that's also from
Vorkuta there were of course within the
camp's there were ways of punishing
people who disobeyed or who failed to
fulfill the norm or who failed to
work as hard as they were supposed to
work and they would be put into special
isolation cells and that's what that's a
picture of that's also from the official
archives those are that's an official
picture how often were you personally
just shocked when you read something you
know it's a funny thing you you become
immune to it you read so many of these
stories that you begin you become very
clinical about it and you you stop
feeling you stop feeling very much and
then suddenly some story mate will
unexpectedly shock you I I think the
things that were hardest for me were the
stories about children either children
whose mothers were suddenly taken away
and were left alone in apartments or
children who were born in camps those
are very very hard stories to read the
cut line on this picture is if you have
your own bowl you get the first portions
that's a quotation from somebody's
memoir people considered people there
was a shortage of everything in camps
including silverware and cutlery and
bowls and people would make bowls people
would steal bowls people would share
bowls and people you know is considered
a great advantage to have your own
because then you could you could go
first to the front of the line instead
of waiting and begging for somebody
else's bowl they surrendered their
bronze skin to tattooing and in this way
gradually satisfy their artistic their
erotic and even their moral needs
that's another quotation from a memoir
and that is a photograph of a criminal
somebody who was part of the
professional criminal gangs that were
very influential and important in the
camps and they were their bodies were
often completely covered with tattoos
that's a doctor examining a prisoner
with a tattoo what about the picture on
the other side of the shower the picture
on the shower is a camp bath again
that's that's a relatively compared to
some of the descriptions of the baths
that's not such a bad picture
they don't look it's not very crowded
but the baths were really just rooms
with bowls of water on the floor and
they would have to wash themselves using
this this picture it looks like all men
sleeping in a barracks type thing what
is this that's actually a hospital
that's those would be those are sick man
and again this is these are all these
are all official photographs taken
the secret police and captain secret
police archives until recently where'd
you find them in the secret police
archives which are now actually they're
still there but you can see them now put
all this in context with Robert conquest
is the great terror he is he still with
the Hoover Institution he is and they
help pay for your book they didn't know
they gave me a fellowship I spent a
month there I used their archives for a
month
and you got a fellowship from Bradley
and a fellowship from Holland yeah these
are all very small yeah a little bits of
money but but he says in the back flap
he says an apple Bob's work is very
human very readable both rich in detail
and highly impressive as an overview of
the huge and dreadful gulag phenomenon
the astonishing story comes alive in a
new way deep feeling combining with deep
understanding how important is he to our
knowledge of this whole story he's very
important
he was really he's really the pioneer he
didn't write directly about the camps
what he wrote about was this the
Stalin's purges own party in 1937 that
was his great book called the great
terror but he was really the first
Western historian to focus so sharply on
the issue of Soviet repression and he
did so at a time when the rest of the
academic community was not so interested
in this subject I can even remember
being at Yale in the 1980s and even then
this is in the early 80s
Robert Congress was considered a little
bit iffy he wasn't considered a really
proper historian because of his
obsession with Stalin's crimes he relied
very much on because there were no
archives he relied very much on the
words of Emma Grace and he relied very
much on accounts of people coming out of
the Soviet Union and this was considered
not quite proper history as it turned
out the Emma grades were right you know
the stories they told were true but
there were there was another group of
historians that preferred to use
official Soviet sources meaning Soviet
newspapers or books that were officially
published to describe to tell the
history of the Soviet Union and he he
simply didn't believe those sources and
he believed that the personal accounts
and that was that was why he was so
important you tell a story on page 441
about ant-man
named Henry Wallace who was he was he
the only American to visit a gulag I
don't know he was the only American
there would have probably been other
American there would have might have
been other official visits but you say
he's a senior American politician to
visit his office first and only time he
was certainly the only person of that
coming he was actually the vice
president of the United States when he
went to Kalama which was the most the
harshest camp and though it was May of
1944 the world record the war was still
going on we were allies with the Soviet
Union and he was completely taken in by
what he saw he believed that he was
visiting a something like an industrial
enterprise local party workers were
dressed up as miners so that he would
see them working in the mines rather
than the emaciated prisoners you say
that and you're right the American press
was wanted to describe Stalin as Uncle
Joe right that was correct why would
they do that because they were our
allies in the war against Hitler did we
think we liked him we liked him
Roosevelt was but was attracted to
Stalin Roosevelt felt that Stalin was a
kindred spirit and he even saw Stalin
you know the United States and the
Soviet Union are new countries so we
together are defeating this old Europe
of aristocracies and this old you know
we are the new countries the countries
of the future let me read what you wrote
about Henry Wallace you say in coolant
Kalama he saw all of his prejudice
confirmed as soon as he arrived he saw
the many parallels between Russia and
the United States both were great quote
new countries carrying none of the
aristocratic baggage of the European
past he believed as he told his host
that Soviet
Asia was in fact the Wild West of Russia
he thought that there were no other two
countries more alike than the Soviet
Union in the United States the very
expanses of your country here virgin
forests wide rivers large lakes all
kinds of climate from tropical to polar
inexhaustible wealth remind me of my
homeland
there was there's other stuff up there
were he says they were he would call big
husky young man free workers who were
far harder working than the political
prisoners whom he supposed that
inhabited the far north in Czarist times
why was he as I guess the word is
buffaloed
he was really comprehensively taken in I
think he later he later took some of
that back when he realized what had
happened but he felt he was visiting our
allied during the war he was visiting
their great industrial enterprise the
gold field and the Soviets put on an
immense show for him I mean they're
actually Soviet archives now describing
this visit and they they put an enormous
ever and they put hundreds of people
into making sure that what he everything
he saw was was kosher that everything
that he saw only the absolute best he
was treated to amazing meals he was he
was given the tour by Nicky chef who was
the who is the secret police chief
commander of the of the of that
particular camp whom I think Wallace
described as something like a CEO he
didn't he didn't understand who it was
that he was meeting and he was simply
given false information from the
beginning to the end and every step of
the way reports about his progress and
what he'd seen and done were but were
sent back to Moscow I don't know the
archives you talk about why we should
care about any of this several times and
including a reference to the current
President Putin and it's correct me if
I'm wrong did you say he was at Cheka he
was Putin wasn't was a member of the
secret police which was later called the
KGB as we know and the old name the
Leninist era name for the KGB is the
Cheka and Putin has described himself as
a checklist which is an old-fashioned
word for secret policeman what is it
what does that mean to you the first
time I heard him said I it it filled me
with horror I mean it's like somebody
saying and I was a member of I was a
brown shirt I mean it's it's him it has
it has very unpleasant connotations why
do you think he says it he says it
because it gives him an aura of
invincibility you know we are the
superior power you know we we were the
group people behind the scene
who were running the old Soviet Union
the term still commands I shouldn't hide
this I mean it so certain commands a
certain amount of respect in Russia I
think a poll was done very recently
saying that some 60 or 70 percent of
Russians still think Lenin was a great
man and contributed to their country so
he he's he's echoing sort of the kind of
respect for the Russian Revolution and
what it achieved or didn't achieve the
day that we're recording this I read in
The New York Times story about Saddam
Hussein would read just like this the
the list that they had the kind of
people that they'd put away the
torturing that went on how much of this
is still going on around the world I
would say a great deal the Stalinist
regime and later the the Khrushchev ayat
and Brezhnev aiight regimes in the
Soviet Union actually spread their
techniques and they taught people around
the world how to run police states I
have no doubt that there were there was
a East German usually they used the East
Germans to do that Saddam Hussein's
police state was probably set up at some
point with Russian or Soviet advise it
is not an accident that so many of these
systems has shares so much in common and
there was a set of techniques they were
deliberately spread the the way that so
the Soviet you the Soviet camp was was
exported to China the Chinese exported
to North Korea the North Korean gulag
North Korean concentration camps that
exist today sound from what little we
know them very like Stalin's gulag you
have any accounting of how many people
were murdered and that whole run from 19
well 17 all the way up through Gorbachev
that's a hard number because you have to
ask I have to know what you mean by that
and that murdered during the revolution
the civil war during the famine there
was an enormous famine in the 1930s it
was it was partly caused or 99% caused
by Stalin's agricultural policies I mean
if you if you add all the many ways in
which as Bob conquest used to say people
died on natural deaths you don't get an
exact number but you do get something
between 15 and 20 million where and
is there any account in that you've seen
why people thought it was alright to
take people out and shoot him they
believed there were people well some
people were following orders some people
believed they were creating paradise on
earth you can't make an omelet without
breaking eggs you can't get to the
perfect society without eliminating the
enemies and that's what they believed
they were doing you have to be very
careful making judgments about why
people did what they did because it's
you have to go back and try and read
their minds it's difficult you have some
other pictures in here this is from 1950
and it's a picture of some guards and
you say that written in the corner is
the word killers yes that was a it was a
picture that somehow somebody who was in
a camp got hold of and she brought that
picture back and that's from her
collection that she then gave to a
memorial in Moscow what did she mean by
killers though those were the people who
ran the camp that she was in and many
people died in that camp and did they
have a system inside the camps where
they would punish you for something that
you did wrong and what would that have
to be you mean where prisoners were
punished or yeah I mean you know you had
to do something wrong like you said the
total joke about Stalin and you went off
to a camp and once you got in the camp
what did you do that then got you
further punished to put in isolation
it was often if you didn't if you didn't
if you refused to work that was the
primary one if you disobeyed the guards
if you attempted to escape if you broke
one of the myriad rules if you if you
were I mean it was all there all kinds
of things that were illegal male/female
fraternization was illegal
many many there were many many things
that could get you into into a prison
cell
there's a picture right below it
anything those are the armed guards the
armed guards were were not part of the
camp hierarchy and that they were not
secret policemen they were they tended
to be sort of more like sold there often
soldiers recruited they were very young
and they ranged enormous ly in their in
their personality I mean some of them
helped prisoners some of them didn't
them probably 95 percent than were
indifferent
and they were the ones who walked around
the rim of the camp and made sure nobody
escaped here's a picture of Stalin and
Yagoda Stalin himself supposedly is five
feet one how tall was you go to your
gutter was they called him the dwarf I
cannot remember his exact height that he
was very short it was he he was the head
of the secret police was then called the
og PU at the very beginning of the camp
system and he he the picture is taken at
some at the White Sea canal which was
one of the first big gulag private
projects what was the biggest project
that the gulags ever conducted I mean
they built things I remember one is it
was at the White Sea project it was a
hundred seventy thousand people involved
yeah well the White Sea Khan was the
first big early project it was it went
and it got the most publicity there were
many other enormous later projects there
were there were the gulag laid most of
the rail lines across the Soviet Union
across Siberia they built the roads
across Siberia they built they dug the
coal mines in Colima they dug the the
coal mines and gold mines and for Kuta
there were an enormous projects okay how
many of these camps are still left as
museums any one one out of all these
camps one and it's it's not even one of
the it's not one of the harshest camps
it's a one-leg poem to which means one
part of one camp called perm 36 which
was actually a camp that came to
prominence in the 1980s as a sort of
place where dissidents were kept has
been turned into a museum by some local
people did you go there I have been
there what do you see when you go there
and where is it it's permison is sort of
at the foot of the Urals can right in
the middle of Russia and you see the
barracks you see you see the fence you
see the place where people went in and
out I should say that in many other
places where there have been camped I
mean in Vorkuta where I've also been the
coal mines which we're all built by
prisoners are all still there and
they're still coal mines so you can you
can visit them and you can see the
places there's a barrack or two left
they're not museums but because they
were working in dust really NERP rises
they're still there
at another point in the book you talk
about the fact that have the 15
republics of the old Soviet system 13 of
them today are run by former communists
maybe it may be a little different out
but when I wrote the book it was that
yes that mean to you it means that the
old the Communist apparatus amount of
power even after the end of the
communist system they had all the
economic power they had tremendous
amount of influence and they were able
to turn their economic power sometimes
after hiatus when a dissident or
opposition groups took over back into
political power again and that's really
has been true almost everywhere so after
all this time thinking about this what
are your conclusion what does it mean to
the Future it's there's there number of
lessons one is the importance of memory
the important owing how this system
worked knowing what what pieces what how
it was done will help us understand
other systems I mean I I don't want to
be too flippant and talking facile
talking about Iraq because it happens to
be in the news or North Korea but it
really is true that this kind of system
has been created over and over and over
again and it really is terribly
important that we we study we study it
and we think about it and we compare
these different systems we try and
understand how they came into existence
what motivates the people who ran them
in order to understand them again it I
am NOT one of these people who believes
you know if we just study it then it
will never happen again because it will
happen again it is happening again
and it may happen many more times it's
terribly important that we understand
what happened the past what did you
learn about the ability of the human
being to live through one of these
things I learned that there's no rule
about that that some people who very
frivolous silly people suddenly find in
themselves something very powerful that
enables them to survive that various
people who seem to be very strong and
important in or
marry life are presented with the
extreme of the camp situation and they
psych collapse completely that it's you
don't you never know people as well as
you think you know them people
confronted with extreme circumstances
people behave in very unpredictable ways
so how long have you work for The
Washington Post editorial board six
months and how often does this
experience that you've had come up
around that table how many how many sit
around the table when you talk about
issues age well some a few more eight
members the board plus a few other
people come I mean not to overdo this
but do people say there she goes again
once in a while I have to be careful
when I bring up Stalin which I I say
funnily enough these kinds of issues
about totalitarian regimes how they're
dismantled how they what happens to the
people who once ran them I mean you were
asking before about former communists
who took over kind of communist
countries I mean this will be an issue
in Iraq when the when we when the Iraqi
government recreates itself what
happened to the former leaders of the
Baathist party will they be in charge
again as almost inevitably has happened
everywhere else and these issues do come
up in all kinds of forms at this
particular moment you have two kids I
remember I have two how old are they
they are two and a half and five and a
half so they haven't gotten to this yet
know what my eldest child knows that
this is my book but he doesn't
understand it I haven't tried very hard
to explain it to and what kind of person
do you expect to read this I I think a
really wide range of people I think
anybody who's interested in contemporary
history in the 20th century history
rather might be I don't expect Russian
or Soviet specialists to read it I think
it's I think it's I've deliberately
written it in such a way that you don't
have to be an expert in order to
understand it I've tried to explain some
of what was happening in the Soviet
Union at the time as a kind of
background
why don't you expect Soviet specialist
to read well no I mean that I hope they
will also read it but I the the idea of
the book was that it would be accessible
to people who don't have any particular
background in Soviet history although I
also hope
specialists will read it and Mina some
have and have liked it so so it's my
hope that they will like it too and what
who is the youngest person it's still
alive today that you talked to that
we've been involved in the gulag at any
point well there were I mean there were
people who arrested in 1953 and there
who are 18 who are in their 60s now and
who are quite sprightly and young and
energetic you've mentioned several times
here the memorial Society how active is
that how effective is that it's actually
it had a bigger it had a bigger presence
a few years back it's now rather small
it's a it's largely funded by Western
foundations it is a group of they do two
things they are they agitate for human
rights in Russia and they also have a
sort of unit a group of people who
really specialize in the history of
Stalinist crimes having something they
are a tremendously good
they have tremendously good historians
they've had they've been extremely
systematic in their use of the archives
they are really the main resource for
for the study of the subject in Russia
find a couple quick questions
hometown originally Washington DC
parents did what father's a lawyer
mother worked in art museums went to
undergraduate yeah what year did you get
out of there 1986 and you went to Oxford
to study what international relations
and what year did you get out of there
I well I spent a year at the London
School of Economics I had a Marshall
scholarship was there and then I was at
Oxford I guess I left in about 1988 to
move to Warsaw the book is called gulag
a history and our guest has been an
Applebaum thank you very much thank you